what's with the jeans hello everybody
and welcome to your mom's house podcast
I am your co-host christina pazsitzky
and the other mommy
the main mommy Tommy is in Australia or
mom Australia the Melbourne Comedy
Festival this week so he will not be
here but I have friends that will sit in
instead I have read ban hi I have the
amazing Nick Youssef hello and I have
with us Matt curse hilarious so yeah
we're gonna we're gonna do it a big
mommy House style we're gonna talk now
Yousef I don't know if my listeners I
don't know if you're familiar with him
but he is a comic that I've known for
many many years and he's a Comedy Store
regular yep it's very funny but we don't
really know Nick Youssef the way we
should know Nick Youssef and we're gonna
get inside of him we're gonna mmm we're
gonna spread his anus and dip our heads
on the side this is all figurative why
your water so I don't know I think I
think we're all reeling in the stand of
community about what the fuck is going
on with Charlie Sheen and his stand-up
attempt I don't know if we're reeling
I'm annoyed it's more annoying than
anything what is it like I don't really
I've just kind of looked at TMZ today
and do you know the I know I don't
there was a point um and it wasn't too
long ago cuz he hasn't been in fully
insane for for very long but I just had
to stop paying attention to it stop
tweeting about it I just started stop
reading cuz people were getting annoyed
they're like
just who no one cares anymore it was
funny for like three or four days with
the tiger blood thing and like the
winning well winning
is now the new that's what she said like
like winning is what's on its way out
and at like auditions winning is the new
nailed it you know like you leave you go
nailed it now people are saying with
this actors have no wit what's the
latest thing in the unit yeah I hate
actors yeah they're kind of the worst I
don't know why it goes on the scale of
suck I think I hate beat Pollack poets
like spoken word poets number one yeah
people folk singers with guitar people
who stare at you and sing okay second
place yeah and then we're on the scale
comedians are annoying as well yeah
we're very small sketch and improv yeah
see that's a lot of people don't know
that in the Santa world that stand-ups
have an inherent animosity let's be
honest words improv errs we believe that
at least I believe that it's kind of
bullshit that it's easier to get a laugh
if it's just an accidental funny ha
right um I don't know if it's easier
it's just more it's just different kinds
of comedy like sketch and improv is a me
and like who the fuck like zany you know
there's some good sketch and improv ah
there's there's definitely I think I
think you're seeing it like Sport comedy
sports or some places yeah I need a
movie Rocky all right the Terminator you
know like you're seeing that exactly
shit there's a lot of awful stand-up -
sure
first set but I feel like it I mean I
did The Groundlings when I first started
comedy and I do feel like when they're
like you're in a coffee shop me and if
you just put the word dick or dildo
people laugh and I was the same as Santa
just with more people on stage of ones
doing so okay so here's my here's my
coach our lisheen is on TMZ it says that
he he opened his shows in Detroit which
is we all know Detroit very funny town
nothing but joy and fine yeah you know
you're off to you you're just like you
know what let's go to a really lucky
City where we can get a lot of super
happy people that are gonna be on board
with this business is booming
and just you know hit the ground running
but yet yet they're also the number one
drug addicts probably in the country and
fucking love fucking hookers and shit
like that so maybe it's like their prime
market that's true
but let's be fair they just got a
Robocop statue in Detroit yeah you know
that is they did they petitioning
they're getting and putting a robot
Robocop that's what they're spending the
little money that they have I got a
boost the Toyota you know but I don't
mean the shit on Detroit I'm not above
it I was born right across from Detroit
in sweet Windsor Ontario my father
worked at the Chrysler Factory so I'm
not I'm not about it
we'll say that but I do think it's an
odd town to start your I just think that
they've been through enough and the last
thing they need is you know Charlie
Sheen coming there yeah you know well
here's here's how he starts he does the
Fox Theater which is good he's not
fuckin with the club's good majority of
the audience heckled not only charlie
but his buddy Simon Rex who came out and
started rapping who the fuck is Simon
Rex
Simon Rex is not anyone anymore he used
to be someone anyway he had a thing for
a while he was like an MTV VJ see the
bald one
no no he was the hot skinny dude he was
on all the MTV whenever they went on
spring break
yeah like Eric I would no shirt on yes
orchestrated the date-rape I was at the
Palms in Vegas this week and that MTV
Spring Break they hire extras because
you have to be over 21 to drink and
college kids are not well used to watch
it and be super bun like oh I'm so lame
yeah I'm TV spring break and then you
realize it's amazing how much fake shit
is you know be like like even just like
extra know if you saw that the extra
that TV show is so broke stir that they
can't afford to have a studio anymore so
now they do this go to like an outdoor
mall and they do their show from an
outdoor mall the Grove yeah the Grove oh
yeah
Access Hollywood no it's extra and they
do it from the Grove and all these
people are surrounding Mario Lopez but
they are all paid extras I've seen that
one because one time I was at the Grove
and I'm like oh it's Mario Lopez who
gives a shit when I was wondering why
people were actually so weird and it's
funny is that my friend Alison is one of
the the paid extras and I had already
released this but it's called Alison's
coming to get you or something like that
but it's hurt she decided to become like
this Terminator character so every time
they show her she's just like looking
around like she's gonna kill somebody
and if she starts staring at Mario Lopez
and then the last time she did it she
like gave him a high-five and I write
when she's done she just started to
stick with like walk looking around like
she's gonna kill everybody that's great
show or what is it Dancing with the
wolves or I think it's pretty straight
actually I hung out with him in Vegas
once and he's knows Joe and although
guys through jujitsu because he does
jujitsu a lot but I mean he was on on
the lookout for definitely women when I
was with him you know yeah that guy has
I mean to you he probably just gets laid
like right after they wrap x-ray he just
walks into the Nordstrom of the Grove
and he's like come on ladies check it
out do you think comedians ever have
that kind of cash a with women when
they're I mean when they're huge
I imagine yeah you have to be like super
Wow Wow Charlie Sheen is probably
getting he is
oh yeah cuz crazy chicks are like yeah
they're probably all over that so like
now he's doing more I thought the whole
tour wasn't just gonna fall apart right
away I get camera he got a standing
ovation in the last town he did he was
in because he went short no II did two
hours oh that's way did you did you tell
me yeah you did two hours I can't think
of a comic even I would like I would
want to watch for an hour and a half
like
even like good ones that I liked after
an hour you're like this there's some
structure in it you know that's just two
hours of that crazy dude just fucking
rambling about bullshit okay it says he
Charlie walks on stage sporting
Cleveland Indians Jersey the crowd goes
well a heckler just asked Sheen where's
your coke reported Charlie is a showing
of a t-shirt that reads genius so he's
just he's talking his March which is
great yeah after several people asked
Charlie about Emilio Estevez he
responded don't you guys want to hear
about me he should have the situation
open for him and just make it the
world's worst show and another audience
chant this time directed toward
Charlie's ex Denise Richards what with
people yelling fuck that bitch dude he's
he says he's not an actual warlock I've
been able to spend magic the past couple
of weeks you guys all about tickets
without knowing a damn thing about this
show wait he's right he had to actually
tell people that he's not a warlock just
in case any of you idiots that actually
bought tickets to this thing that I'm in
the cast spell may cause diarrhea and
I'm not stupid people are though like
they think the TV's like I'm sure people
want to be witched I can't where do they
charge like what's the admission for his
show ten bucks
right it's gotta be a temple no no I
think it's actually pretty high yeah I
think it was really high actually and
and I don't know like did they actually
say that they were advertising as a
comedy show cuz I was kind of gandered
it was more of like a variety that's
what I thought too
you know that guy's Saturday Night Live
of Charlie Sheen like the first the
first one that they had they actually
even had skits like video skits were
like iPhone applications and stuff like
like animation like short movies that
they were playing yeah stuff like that
like it seemed like maybe the first time
they were I don't know if it's changed
since then but like the you know they
got rid of the comic Kirk Fox after the
first one wait Kirk so Kirk Fox did the
first one he did only the first one that
I heard and I heard that say yeah the
second one they didn't use them that
they I think they bailed out of the idea
of having either either having a
stand-up or having hurt I don't know so
Kirk was the opener
yeah he was the famous opener that was
you know you see the YouTube videos yeah
like that and and before I even knew
this like uh I was reading like a
breakdown of it when we were in Portland
Oregon because we were like on our green
room like looking at the Twitter and
going oh shit what's happening with this
Charlie Sheen shit yeah and then uh so
crazy
yeah then so this one website was like
breaking it down per hour and was like
oh god Connor came on you know this joke
this joke beginning booed you know
Charlie Sheen at one point I guess came
out and tried to like know this comics
really funny you know like halfway
through his act with in attendance but I
feel like you know it's that's a gig
that any comic would take first of all
if they approached me I'd be like
absolutely I'll open I don't give a fuck
give me the paycheck but that's like
you're showing up for a bloodbath like
you're showing up for the freak show
it's kind of like opening for a band if
you are open for a band Nick yeah
it's why Kurt Fox they're not there to
see you I mean you're Charlie Sheen you
get it you need a Norton you need a Jim
Norton you need a you know like you know
what I mean I think there is that could
work I just think that why would they
get like a tall skinny nerd nerd charlie
it makes the Charlie Sheen doesn't
really work it's like yeah you're
walking into a firing squad there's no
need a Bilborough yes he probably just
wanted a lesser person so the whole show
could be about him right no I mean
because he's good at that have you ever
seen dubbers Liberty bill the Liberty
Bell bit on YouTube I don't think so it
was at a concert where Bill started
getting booed there's one of the best
yeah one of the best funniest clips ever
and like I said that would be perfect
for somebody like Bill burr or Jim
Norton but bill burr would be able to
fucking destroy that he's gonna lose no
fight mom's house podcast listeners I
don't know if you know this but there's
a little beef gun there's nobody
it's so it's so annoying if you wanna
let Sun Rogen's podcasts always where as
part of the death squad family we like
to address beef and serve it up on a
plate live on the internet so did you
have fun at Southwest that your first
time no I went last year but not under
official South by comedy we did our own
like the Comedy Store and the Roxy did
like a joint thing together at a venue
there last year and we did that and it
was fun and then we just you know
watched a bunch of music and hung out
and drink excessively okay I tell you it
sounds like a little bit of a nightmare
for me it's oh it's long fucking it's
long and exhausting cuz it's not like a
music festival like like if you went to
Coachella or Bonnaroo where it's like
one area then you can just watch
whatever you want like all of downtown
Austin is just overrun by skinny jeans
people like tattooed hipster musicians
and everyone's hammered all day long and
like and then there's the interactive
like nerdy guys all the tech dudes and
stuff so you have like a mix of all that
did you take over downtown Austin and
it's like from 9:00 or 10:00 in the
morning till like 4:00 a.m. you're just
constantly doing something all day long
keeping myself badass barbecue all day
dude Austin's rad though I love this
awesome such a great arena
love to live there but I feel like I
hate festival like I just did the Aspen
Comedy Festival which was fun cuz it's
just comics yeah and it's just you
bullshitting with other comics and
everything I like hanging out more than
I do anything else yeah I haven't we're
going like Lollapalooza when I was 14
and doing acid and just wanting to die
cuz there's so many people you can't pee
it gets yeah I'm getting to the point
where I'm too old for music no I swear
it sounds stupid no you are great you
are how old are you I'm 28 oh yeah but
like I've gotten it like say Coachella
I've gone the last five years in a row
and every year we go we get there like
the night before we camp we said like oh
you dirty him and we go for really hit
the roof get it ready fan thirty bar
that's what we did the first year
though they mark the experience they
raped you with hotels over there it's
fun to camp it's like this is 15
thousand person camping no I don't go to
music festivals for camping oh yeah I
like a mechanics fun it's well I can't
like oh here's what happened like I
first need two years ago we were we were
camping and having a good time or
whatever and then we we it's like day
two or whatever and yet you get up at
like 8 a.m. because it's like 9,000
degrees right so we get up and we're
just tired and hungry want coffee and
air conditioning and like all the
amenities that you can't have until like
Monday when you get home so we look over
at the tent like kind of across from us
and there's all these like punk-ass kids
that are like 21 like yeah and they'd
like it looked like they had not gone to
sleep and then I go over there and I'm
like what's up guys you guys still
hanging out too like yeah we're partying
John's done so much it's so crazy I look
at this
people still do ecstasy oh yeah Roman
the little asshole looks at me and goes
maybe not people your age fuck you that
guy just like called me an old guy yeah
I was like fuck fuck I wanted to be like
hey man so I wanted to like do when
you're on e make sure not to drink water
run along yeah oh yeah kids do you know
I heard they don't do acid and like
crystal like all the awful shit we did
usually did use the Shrimant all that
shit right okay the last time you did
nice and early
oh I started early I started at 14 and
then I ended by the time I was 20 I was
like I took a good smoke weed I took his
good seven years off and I just recently
last week or two weeks ago she roomed
again for my first time and I was it was
mostly because the last time I did was
so awful I was like you know what I'm
done with this I'm too old for this shit
like that but man it was one of the most
like reset my life I felt like I feel
like more creative again I feel like
fucking like a whole new breath of fresh
air where were you at it was fucking
beautiful right
where were you got just my girl's house
no no in natures over the best just get
out of the box yeah but yeah I would
recommend it if you if you took it off
if you'd went through the thing I did
like you know why I just not I'm not
doing that shit anymore if I'm gonna go
get some shrooms and I did it different
like I made a tea out of it I didn't
just fucking chow it down like I used to
yeah and it was just like I was just
drinking Nick just sipping on this tea
and next thing you know everything was
beautiful it was amazing well I don't
know I feel like gay I feel like when I
was 20 that was the last time I was to I
was too old and I had too much going on
and responsibility was still in college
but I remember I'd lasted almost like a
full day because I took one whole day
almost it was almost 20 hours and I was
I was up at like 4:00 in the morning put
acid on your mushrooms and I was
watching mr. Rogers I remember at like
5:00 in the morning just twitching and
freaking out and being like this is it
this is the last time I do it and that
was like 14 I started drugs when I was
13 I smoked weed for the first time in
LA like you know to fucking Valley you
know where did you grow up I grew up in
La Crescenta okay yeah you know yeah so
you guys didn't go did you ever go to
Hollywood and Melrose I mean maybe like
a few times but none of us had cars none
of us had money like it wasn't like one
of those like let's go party in
Hollywood were like let's go play
Warcraft you know and like my friends
den or something all night the bus sign
I bust that shit over I just take the
bodies like Glendale and that was like
this huge journey for me I'm like am I
gonna come back it's so far the calorie
I rescued my dog from the Galleria
that's the old one before the American
yeah they film movies there and should I
grew up on that I grew up on the food
court yeah we used to play we used to
play a game at the mall like see if you
can find more than three hot girls in
the Glendale Galleria and I think maybe
maybe twice we were able to get like
four four and a half but then you go to
Holly which is just gorgeous eleven like
everywhere yeah that's funny I always
tell people that because I'm 34 now and
in LA I'm maybe like 6 ok but in Toledo
I'm a fucking 10 yeah because like
anywhere outside you're kind of normal
like you you look good it's a hard city
to be attractive in like but we grew up
here and I feel like you have a
different I don't know I when you grow
up in this shit it doesn't it doesn't
affect you the same way I think yeah you
cuz yeah yeah I mean you get accustomed
to it like you know what's seeing
celebrities and stuff it's not one of
those like oh my god yeah even before
you know we started doing comedy I'm
sure you'd be like others
what's-his-name from that one movie and
then you look great yeah it looks fatter
and old in real life
yeah but yeah it's um yeah it's so hard
to be like I was in Raleigh a few weeks
ago and it's fun it's the south and you
know like no one's real thin and
emaciated and you know now right I'm on
stage talking about like eating off some
Carolina barbecue or whatever and some
guy in the crowd he goes he's like yeah
man you need to eat like yelled it out
like and in my head I'm like I got I
can't eat too much food so I'm gonna you
know I'm gaining weight or whatever and
this guy's like worried about my health
and I'm like do I need to eat is like
yeah man what's you know are you okay
I'm like just like perception is so
crazy like I got called I was in Vegas
at the Palms this last week and I walked
out on stage I didn't even say a fucking
word yeah and I got a drunk guy in the
audience just goes how did you deduce
that this is so classy that's the
classiest place to be broken I did a USO
tour once and we were in Japan and I
walk on stage and the dude let's go home
faggot Oh
yeah you're right I should guess what I
get to go home tomorrow you're in the
army you'll be here for another two
years later I'm feeling red van likes
Vegas no I used to love Vegas for about
two times and then after the second time
I'm there like almost every other month
or every month now and I fucking hate it
I hate it so much
and in like last time I had the best
time I had at Vegas in a long time and
it was only because of the some crazy
heaven I think I already talked about
good about where this hot girl followed
me to my room
why no think about this this is actually
plan to talk about this on some podcast
before but I went into the elevator it
was the end of the night it was like
4:00 a.m. and there was like this girl
wearing this beautiful dress just look
very rich and very made-up and stuff
like that and she's just like texting
and then she missed her floor and I was
like oh you can get off at my floor no I
said you could stay in my room tonight
or something like that I was so drunk I
just said something cheesy like and she
looks at me it goes okay what the fuck
and so I come out the elevator I go to
my room she follows me all the way to my
room I opened up the door she comes
inside immediately she pushes me against
the wall grabs my dick and starts making
out with me why this chick was like
Kardashian she was taller than me she
was just like a supermodel chick we make
out for like five minutes and she goes
if you wanted to play you have to pay
and like I said I thought you were a
real girl and I was like I just said I
thought you're a real girl then she gave
me one for free she made out with me for
a little bit longer than she left but
Wow and I think I think I said something
like I was almost gonna say like if you
know after you're done I'm going to just
spin herself $2,000 by the way two grand
really sleep was cheaper than when I was
in Amsterdam in 2003 in the red-light
district I asked the hookers there you
know you see them behind the glass and
everything yeah I said 50 euro you can
do anything I said anything ain't all
she was yeah anything 50 euros so 50
euros like a hundred bucks right brand
for this special she was fuckin crazy
how she deaf
was topping she was definitely like Puff
Daddy top children
worth 2 grand if I was rich I would
definitely hire her if I had to she
didn't look like a hooker she just
looked like a super fucking hot model
like you know like hookers you go to LA
or go to Vegas you can walk through the
casino and see hooker hooker yeah you
know this did not look I would never
have guessed this chick was a hooker
accept the fact that she followed to
Miami to my room and yeah so I heard
this thing on I forget where and it was
this this professor that did research on
prostitution yeah and she was under the
belief that all all women that became
prostitutes were molested as children
and aren't doing it of willful choice
like it isn't a choice it's just like
you're you don't you know what I mean
like your life circumstances are such
that that is all you can do I mean do
you know hookers are you know pornstar I
know hookers I don't know any hookers
well hookers and escorts same thing just
let's get that right there's a
difference big there's a hooker that
walks the street and the hooker that
fucking gets in the mail and fucking
goes your house or mistletoe and the big
thing with the escorts now is like
especially with strippers nowadays
strippers people aren't making money so
you go to a strip club
these girls are now resorting to
escorting and what escorting is or what
porn stars are even doing nowadays is
fucking doing escorting because instead
of doing like a porn video that's going
to be put on the internet and everyone
will see they'll make more money just to
have fucking sex with you there's no
money employed anymore right there's the
internet you may as well just be a
hooker and charge some guy two grand all
right and then get the fuck out and then
your parents and your family and your
old school teacher doesn't have to see
you getting anal yeah I mean getting
gangbanged my five black guys have you
got the biggest nun the biggest
difference obviously is the the safety
part of it because with porn is actually
one of the safest things in a row
because every time they do anything they
have to do AIDS test yeah here's the
fallacy in that argument because I was
debating this and if they wear condoms
now - oh oh that's cool that's why
yeah it's more real but you watch porn
coz it's not realistic no no no I won
I see porn to me I can't do the glamour
porn like if you either like glamour
porn or you don't
I want to fucking see their fucking
canceled check on the nightstand or
their their insurance like car insurance
I want to fuckin see a shaky camera I
want to see it real as possible that
girl has a fuckin ingrown hair on her
inner thigh I want to see that no I
don't like pornography I don't like the
aggression I'm sick of the spinning and
the pulling apart and I like all that I
mean not when it's like to a degree we
like Jesus Christ they're gonna be okay
like I don't want to worry about anybody
it's definitely changed a gear they
definitely have amped it up and the way
I have to look at her butt oh it's like
a giant yeah like they show the gaping
hole yeah with the love mustard in it I
don't need to see I don't know my music
I'm a girl and to not see that all of
them I still lose it
have you ever had sex with a girl from
behind in the spreader ass open and spit
inside her asshole you're done with a
chest cold here's my prediction is that
he's got a pinky toe in the porn world
now yeah and I predict that he will do a
film or something related it's more the
fist no no now right why keep it a
mystery bro did you do all this I don't
need to yes you need to because you like
it no i don't i actually don't even
watch porn I don't even like oh oh
master but if I if I'm not fucking if
I'm if I'm not fucking somebody and then
I'll watch some porn but it's more like
hey what's on you know submit your
flicks
bam bam I'm done you know no I don't buy
porn videos and I buy porn magazines I
don't do any of that doesn't even have a
you would be amazed at least with
penthouses you'll be amazed just the
people that pick it up at airports and
fucking you know I mean your wife is
exactly hard copy porn under for the old
ladies and I feel bad when I'm watching
a movie on the plane and it's like a sex
scene or something like that yeah and
what's your wife's stance on pornography
um she she's totally cool with it I mean
yeah she's she's she's good about it
she's just you know don't ask don't tell
ya we laugh there's this one last year
about have you ever seen this it's where
the girls kick guys in the balls no no
and it's like something porn yeah I
guess funnies Home Videos move on woman
and she's like whatever language and she
fuckin keeps kicking the guy in the
balls until he's like shaking mm-hm and
I'm like I could do that for free I
would so love to kick a guy in the balls
that's like the that's the kind of porn
Jason can watch what they're like yeah
but that's the kind of porn a guy would
be like I would be uncomfortable but
it's every time she kicked him I'd like
is it for talking about it makes me
wince but it's a humiliation I think the
degradation yeah that he enjoys I guess
it's like good old fucking lassic man
comments need to be injured while I'm
having sex like that's not good I don't
either I feel like I don't know I'm very
vanilla I'm very like I feel like might
get my kicks on stage yeah I put my life
out there for people right so that's
enough
enough like I don't know but then you
look at guys like greg Giraldo or right
they just do blow and drugs and hookers
on did he do hookers he did right intro
about strippers
seems like most comics do hookers yeah I
ever said don't I feel like every time I
say I don't people really haven't done
that but I've never done this and I want
I want to try it out of pose do it let's
do it like I want to try one right now
like I was we have one podcast with this
guy that was addicted to hookers a comic
that I want to say his name because we
had to like put a spider-man mask on him
the whole time while he was saying
that's hilarious and so he was talking
about how much he gets hookers and
everything on what he does and like one
of the things he does is he always gets
massages and he and that actually I
always thought was yeah it may be some
places to handjob I didn't know that you
could get full-on sex at massage day I'm
pretty sure but I want to start try that
but I want to like do baby steps of that
like I want to go to one of those places
at the mall where you're sitting weird
in the middle of the court room I'm just
like hey you know 10 bucks you know and
they throw a sheet on you and spit in
your face or something you want to get
arrested at a mall no I just want I want
some kind of like that seems like that
would be easier to do then go into like
a real you know massage parlor place
right I want to start off at fucking you
know Sam's word I want you just wonder
how like unsafe a massage parlor what
that is because it's not like the porn
world where there's testing and all that
stuff and some chick at a massage parlor
like jerking you off
I've heard stories of boys getting yeah
that's because you can still get herpes
and gentle warts with her they're only
16 it's not like they've gotten a try so
much more 16-year old Thai girl right
off the boat Oh in that case then I'm
yeah they use of you wouldn't get
prostitute everything I'm not well I
don't know I would never say never and
stuff like that but like cuz I just
don't know what I would do in the future
but yeah I've never done it and I don't
it's not something I want to do no you
know man
I get laid no but even yeah even guys
that do get laid still get hookers and
so that's not like you know I guess you
know my dad is is like 64 and he'd AIDS
20 year olds and he's like good for him
so right yeah amazing but um and he
always says he's like I don't know why
anybody would get a little girl to
forcing sex cuz it to me it just seems
like you what you are in essence doing
it against there well like you know once
you want a willing happy woman
under you on top of you I think they are
happy they're making fucking hundreds of
dollars for doing nothing but doing sex
like one of the girls I know that that
that does escort her on track she
fucking love sex she's like dude I love
fucking dick and me she's like I could
either do that or I could get paid a
shitload of money and not have to do
anything else for them you know I have a
awesome house I get two cars if we're
just having doing something I love
that's gotta be taxing on your soul
though okay
she likes money it's not sex that's what
she says but it's just it's fun look
it's money I do it for free
see ya thanks so much that you do it for
free yeah what if you if you you could
pick girls that wanted to pay you to
have sex with you what like you every
day you got five girls going hey I want
to hire you and I want to fuck you
how much is your how much did it cost
would you do that so become a gigolo
just for the title I like the word yeah
yeah that's kind of weird
I don't know first of all I don't know
that any girl would be like I need to
have sex to do so man no I'm just saying
let you say yes here's money first no
I'm saying what if it was up that's
that's what these girls are pretty much
saying you know yeah I mean yeah I mean
I understand why some of them do it but
I just still think they're all broken
people for sure I think they're all as
happy as they they seem and like I got
cars and money and I'm smiling right now
it's like you know there's times at
night were there at home and they're
just like wow can I tell you Sam Tripoli
said the best thing about this he was
like you know Christina pornstar DNA and
stripper DNA is not that far off from
comedian DNA right and I was like you're
right like it's a it's a double helix of
like uncle's lap and early menstruation
but it's also you know we use our words
to get attention and yes these girls
maybe used their bodies right it's a
different form of love me daddy
basically yeah it's all grab for
attention and yeah you know we're sick
like what we do is fucking ridiculously
mentally ill yeah it's kind of if you
think about it too much you're like this
is weird like my choices in life are
really unusual like yeah you're staying
up late and traveling just to mohawk in
front of people and make them oh it's
terrible and knowing that like public
speaking is people's number one fear in
life and and we do that like it's just
you're so vulnerable it's counter yeah
but you started early by the way how old
are you when you started 18th so jealous
well don't be it's not going well no
it's a thank you
no how did you have the wherewithal to
start so early like it's so good I don't
know I just wanted to do it when I was a
kid and then I lived in you know LA and
it was like all right there and I was
like because I like as a kid I was very
like lazy in school and just fucked
around I was like and I was like you
know getting up like approaching like
you know legal adulthood and I was like
I need to start doing this or I probably
never will yeah so I'm like no matter
what you know College happens with that
I need to start doing this when I'm
still dying to get it you know get it
going so I just I opened like an LA
Weekly or something and then just found
an open mic at the fucking haha cafe
night so we had open mic at like 4:00 in
the afternoon or whatever yeah and
that's some fast food job or something
and I asked my boss at the time who's
like my friend I'm like hey man I'm
doing this like and I was all shy about
my pigeons thing you know so what are
you doing I'm like I'm gonna I told him
I wanted to do comedy I'm like I'm doing
this open mic everybody's like oh wow
he's like yeah get you know leave early
whatever time you need and and then and
that just became like every day I'd
leave work early and go do those open
mics and then just yeah it just started
well cuz I remember seeing you at the
Comedy Store and around open mics when I
was just starting yeah I think I was 26
34 now and you're so young and cute you
still are but you know punk rock shit on
your your wrist and you're always
listening to cool but you were so
diligent and I really like that about
you I thought that was so cool you're so
young and so aware what you liked and
know now your parents are immigrants too
though right yeah
where are you yeah they hated it like
every parent you know American or not
they're gonna be like why are you
throwing your life away now I think with
immigrant stuff is worse because you're
like my parents escape from fucking
Hungary and 69 later
I'm telling you escaped under barbed
wire fences put in a camp in Italy for a
year and then have our only child
their only child drop out of law school
after two weeks and be like guess what
I'm gonna be a comic like my mother
didn't speak to me for almost a year so
yeah I mean she's you know she's her own
special breed it's dead are you the only
child
no I have a younger younger brother
who's not in like entertainment or
anything what does he do he works in the
family business what's your family
business like a marble granite oh yeah
that's a good it's a very like yeah yeah
like construction does he move here you
have nothing and like you know and you
just you have to do something like that
where you know those skills a lot of
people you know have like growing up
like you know working with your hands
and they're so it's easier to start
doing that so I'm sure my dad's a
forklift mechanic he's
business and yeah yeah he does he does
well now but yeah the plant yeah the
plan was I was yeah like you're gonna be
in the family business or be a doctor it
was like well like to do one of these
things oh yeah and then I started doing
comedy and like immediately I was like a
much happier or still angsty and young
and you know angry kid I'm still angry
but I was at I was so much happier after
starting and then they were just
miserable they thought it was my hobby
for the first four years are you bored
with this yet I'm like no I'm actually
having more fun than ever and I'm
getting good and then they eventually
like one day cuz you know parents are
they like after a while they're like
this is something he wants to do and
he's happy and then in the end all he
wanted ruined your happiness yeah so
when they realized it was actually
making me happy and it's what I wanted
to do and it wasn't some hobby or a joke
or anything yeah all right we get it
well now what I do or do they know yeah
now they're good with it now yeah
they're fine with it cuz my parents will
never be proud of me I really like yeah
like I remember one of the first few
times I was on Chelsea Lately I'm like
dad I'm on Chelsea Lately isn't that
he's like what this gel see lately yeah
well what is the e-channel what are you
talking about they don't know like and
it's like wow man only wanted approval
and that's never good but I feel like
you know the driving that works I have a
question for you yes my dear are you
still going on Chelsea here and there
dunno no did you ever hear whatever
happened at Justin Martin doe who's
Justin Martin he's a friend of mine that
that was supposed to be been hired by a
Chelsea and then the Christmas party
happened and he drank too much and
blacked out there I guess the Christmas
party they were just hanging out tequila
to every everyone and then he drank so
much and blacked out and then he mix
remembers coming to and like Whitney
Cummings was driving him home or
something like that instead that they
were kicked out of the party and then
the next day that he lost his job from
that or whatever and they never really
they offered the to his job that they
already offered him to somebody else or
something like that but uh but the no
one knows and no one can remember she's
he ending the last thing he said was
like I remember the dude from the Black
Eyed Peas
and I'm like wait the Black Eyed Peas
was there she what they do
I was just starting to be on that show
last Christmas so I wasn't invited to
the Christmas party mm-hmm but there are
a lot of things like that that occur in
that world yeah and I one day I will
love to tell the tale okay
I fear that right now might be TLC
making you know one day one day the
tell-all book down good lord
you know the show business show business
is a wacky place it's full of all kinds
of people
everyone's a weirdo and everyone's got
some story yeah
and I'm but that's why it's a good place
to be if you yourself are kind of fucked
up which I think or if you like things
yeah yeah I love when you have like
civilian friends that are like you gotta
meet my buddies but you know sometimes
they can be offensive or say I'm like
the world I live in
it's all good generate no pass holes
like don't worry about it unless my
introduction is him punching me in the
head like no he's fine I don't really
have many civilian friends anymore just
cuz I can't censor right like I can't
not be a complete asshole what's the
point like they're not talented or
retract this what he needs those people
yeah it's great
oh the kids think god damn it how much
do I not want to hear about people's
fucking kids like oh my friends having
kids yeah I mean a few of them doing but
but yeah I mean more more and more of my
friends are starting to get like married
oh you're very much okay yeah everyone
around is like so we're moving in
together we're getting a vomit all over
your life how do you feel about about
that are you gonna hold out or are you
seeing somebody now yet yeah
I'm in no position to get married though
like with anybody that's that's you know
down the road you should wait I was 32
when we got married yeah so there's no
hurry
yeah are you courage to have kids and
stuff no no no I've been married twice
no really yeah good first one out of the
way
young yeah for you I'm I don't I don't
feel commitment I'm in yeah I don't need
it I'll figure it out we break up but
this shit happens you know III like
Mogami that's fine yeah yeah I'm cool
with commitment now like when it you
know I mean I still want to fuck other
people I do have a dick but for now I
just had my I just had my ex-fiance get
re-engaged the other day like she's the
girl that had moved to California with
dater for 70 years
oh yeah yeah and so it's I it's weird
it's like like it's not like I'm like
jealous like I can't believe it you know
or whatever it's just weird to think
that like okay now she's gonna do what
we were supposed to do oh yeah
believe me I'm not concerned or at all
it's just kind of when it first heard
about it was like weird yeah it is weird
like I lived with a guy before I married
Tommy like for four years I lived I
lived with a civilian he was a lawyer
and now he's married he just had a kid
and I thought that I give a shit about
him anymore like I don't have feelings
but it is like this thing where you're
like wow I spent so much time with you
we lived together like yeah yeah we were
almost gonna do what you're doing right
now and how I'm so glad that I'm not his
wife right didn't have a kid but it is a
weird like a huge chunk of your life and
that's like ex-wife man you just like
wow I have a relationship with her
friendly but still it's like in ten
years like yeah I got divorced ten years
ago like yeah crazy it's like oh okay
well dating like being in relationships
so and then you break up and one day
it's like you're dead to me and you just
mourn this thing and yeah whole thing
the break-up obviously is the wart oh
that's the worst part you act out in
weird ways listen you're always gonna be
the asshole just know that tap out just
say F you're right I'm a dick just get
your shit and get the fuck out it's okay
Omega knows my philosophy on breakups is
that the old the best cure for an old
dick is bounce on a new one right
that's what I try to do the Brahmin love
your dummy it definitely gets you over
it as soon as possible but then you find
yourself jumping into something you
haven't really researched I don't yeah
it's it's just like a good it's a good
way to forget you just go out and meet
some girl and you know see your yeah
it's not a cure but you know you're very
attractive you've always been one of the
better-looking boys on the circuit I
imagine that you pull a lot of tail it's
remember I sound like the Laika's I
never listen to him that was too fucking
macho deformation so correct me it would
seem to me that you would do well I do
all right
I was Starbucks well what am I gonna be
like yeah I mean I do I do okay I guess
I saw a girl that I had a fling whether
we call it at Starbucks before I got
here Wow and I was like she's like I
guess she's a comic now right yeah she's
second last night she has like a blog
and like she hangs out the comedy scene
she's turning to calm she's very sweet
um but yeah so I saw this girl and I was
like how fuck and I know she saw me more
why and I was about to take my
sunglasses off like well but where she's
sitting
it's all my coffee's ready wow she
didn't recognize I didn't see you I
don't know if she did she's like wait I
recognized a matching watch with shirt
is that Nick by the way yellows my new
favorite color yeah yellows good is it
like is yellow back or something cuz
lately a yellows been popping up all
over the place
yah goes back well they're good for you
little towel you know yeah now I'm
seeing somebody so I can't you can't
fuck yeah I don't know how well I would
be doing she's so amazing it doesn't
matter I like her a lot this is I'm
repulsed by every everybody I've slept
with before my husband really that makes
sense is that normal
I find them everyone gusting everyone
person I don't but I look back in
repulsion pretty much with everybody oh
wow it's not what I owe time but even
Boone didn't have a dollar for the vase
you Charlie maybe every single person
you're pretty much I'm completely
disgusted by my choices of sexual
partners in the guy that you live with
for four years sexually repulsed yeah
are you weird about sex is that why is
it like a shameful thing so then you're
like oh I can't believe I did that I
think it is a little bit of that I think
it's the Catholic guilt I do have a lot
of shame okay but I'm not weird about
sex I'm very open about that at least in
a kick him with my husband I'm fine
right but I was never promiscuous and I
do kind of regret that because I think
now that you're married yeah yeah no no
I was in college I was like I switch I
can find a lot of people but if you guys
have like shame number one and I'm
afraid of STDs number two I'm deathly
good like I'm gonna get herpes it's
gonna ruin my life and that was my major
deterrent was like I think I mean that's
every bit like I think literally every
city every time I've ever had sex I'm
like I have herpes like this
automatically then you go get tested
your font but it's like the biggest
worry okay in this city it's female yeah
in San Francisco where I was like
bisexual everybody's bisexual and and
not attractive there's no attractive
people in smelly it's all just yeah
weird androgynous looking hippie people
it might be just the bear sex a lot of
people that haven't had
sex with a big hairy cuddly guy like
myself anyways and we done enough I feel
like we've done a lot of show yeah well
I'm so glad you guys came along thank
you courage Nick Youssef and red bag
what work will attaining this yes oh
okay I am at christina p that's my
twitter and then I am at Nicki Yusef ni
ck y ou u SS e F and I'm at ma TT y que
ir SCH many curse I'm red banner ad ba
and and this podcast and all the podcast
we do can be found at death squad TV or
death squad on iTunes so please hit
subscribe he's gonna come back here with
Tom it's so much more he'll be back next
week yes well thanks for listening bye